foreign
Bianca is in San Diego hi Bianca how are
you
hi I'm great thanks for taking my
Michael sure what's up
so my husband and I have about a 200k in
debt not including our mortgages we have
two homes one we live in and one that we
use as a rental we both are on board
paying off debt we're tired of being in
debt but we have different paths that we
think we can get there faster so the
home that's our rental he had that
previously before he met me basically he
took over it from his grandfather that
was going to go into foreclosure so
that's how he has that home I would
personally want to sell that home and
use the equity in that ticks mouth are
dead and he's more thinking he wants to
keep that other house and just be really
intentional and work more hours and pay
it off um just like gazelle intense so I
kind of wanted to give you that advice
you have two hundred thousand dollars in
debt that is not mortgages
yes on what
well it's one of your favorite words a
hundred thousand on HELOC which was a
bad idea we have 80k in student loans
and about 20 on solar nothing on cars
no cars payments no okay what was the
HELOC for paying off all bills
when we purchased the home we basically
purchased this home that we're in now my
daughter has special needs and we needed
to get her into a better school district
and we basically bought like the ugliest
house on the nicest Street if that makes
sense so it needed like a full there was
like
um cracks everywhere in the concrete we
had to do a lot of upgrades to it to
just get it livable
so this was for repairs
yes how much is your first mortgage
so the one we live in yeah the one with
the HELOC
yeah it's six hundred thousand what's
the house worth
um I just looked at Zilla today it's
worth 9.75 okay cool and the other house
that was his Grandpa's has how much owed
on it
350. and what is it worth
when I looked today it was worth 620.
okay and how long have you all been
married
uh we've been married five years
okay
what's our household income
um right now it's about 115 to 130. um I
was working but my mother recently got
really ill with cancer so I'm taking
care of her right now and we have a
special needs daughter so it's just his
income
okay the house she got from his grandpa
that was in foreclosure was that a a
family property uh by that I mean does
it have
history with the family or was this just
a place Grandpa lived
it's kind of a long story like kind of
messy but basically he lived there and
then he was going to lose it because he
made some bad financial investments you
told us it was in foreclosure well does
it have family history or not
yeah all of his his mom grew up there
his aunts everybody grew up in that
house
so really that's his reasoning for not
selling it not some kind of financial
decision
yeah I think I think there is an
attachment I think sometimes also he
thinks like oh you know we don't know
how our daughter our daughter is going
to develop and he thinks like the more
property and more stuff like income we
can uh generate for her yeah until you
took out a hundred thousand dollars
HELOC to fix a cracked sidewalk
yeah yeah it kind of kind of screwed
that plan up
like I want to do something good for my
special needs daughter so we're going to
go deeply in debt no that that those two
things are counteract are
counterproductive he's got a really
expensive bucket bailing water on a ship
with a hole in it
he needs to stop and plug the hole in
the yeah you guys got to sell this
house you gotta sell the house
I'm sorry I hate it because it does have
memories and it is going to break a part
of his heart and that's why he doesn't
want to sell it but um you're uh needs
your daughter's needs the future of your
house is much more important than the
past of that other house
okay and another way another way to
think of it is
instead of trying to prop up this idea
of Legacy in in these four walls of this
house
be able to sit back and say
my granddad bought this house raised
families here and set us up in a
position that we could change our family
tree when it comes to our money yeah and
what's your daughter's name
her name's um Natalia
Natalya okay would you do me a favor
don't you ever blame your stupid butt
financial decisions on your daughter
again
okay that's so wrong
my special needs daughter gave me
permission to do stupid stuff no
you have an extra responsibility to not
do stupid stuff in the name of having a
special needs daughter
not I have a special needs daughter so
we had to do this
if you keep using her as a cloak for
your stupid stuff you're going to keep
doing stupid stuff because it gives you
permission to do anything if you call on
the nobility of taking care of special
needs and that is not a fact
so quit doing that you've got to stop
that and you guys have to get yourself
if you're going to sell this house and
pay off everything you've also got to
get on a budget you've got to get under
control you've got to make every dollar
behave because you'll go back into this
mess if you blame Natalia for your next
stupid thing again like this house you
bought that was all the pieces
and then you went in debt further after
buying the house uh and and but used it
all as a rationalization to make that
move and you just can't do that you've
get you know next time you get ready to
buy a car we'll have a special needs
daughter I don't care
I don't care you still can't buy a car
if you can't another money to buy it you
got to stop this you've got to stop this
and and so you guys have got to get
yourselves under control the danger of
selling the house is you guys don't
change your decision-making processes
and your habits and you're going to go
back in debt but truthfully
mathematically you need to sell the
house you're right and get rid of all
this debt and get it off of you but only
if you both raise your right hand and
Pinky swearing spit Shake too never make
decisions that involve debt again ever
and live on a written budget where you
live on lesson you make and um listen
stuff comes at all of us
relatives get cancer people pass away
children have struggles stuff comes at
all of us you've got to have a process
that involves you to live your life
without sacrificing the quality of your
life on the altar of the bad things that
come at you
this is the Ramsey Show